so where are we going uh upstairs
is this where you spend most of your
time oh a big chunk of it yeah
I've come to meet 13 year old Charlie
for the last few years he's refused to
go to school basically everyone my name
comes in and she tries to get me up I'm
like nope not doing it and then she
keeps getting mad at me and then she
keeps coming in and saying Charlie get
your clothes on I'm saying nope
in the last three years he spent just a
handful of days in class what is it
about school that you're not keen on the
people the teachers the classes
the uniform if I don't go to school I
know I'm letting
my man and my dad down my mum said that
uh she disappointed in me when I went to
a stayover
um that's about it that's all I really
need to say
and how did that make you feel
sorry I'd obviously but
he said I guess
Charlie is bright he's got lots of
friends and reports suggest when he's in
school he works hard and behaves but he
still refuses to go
right every morning go in Wake Charlie
up calling him and calling him
I put his school uniform on the bed tell
him to get in it get his jumper on
trousers shirt all the time him saying
no I don't want to go I don't want to go
do you think you and Dad should be doing
more to get him for school we've dragged
him in the car
crying dad's even lifted him out of a
van at one point to put him in the gate
and he just lost his Rag and ended up
punching a wall
she says some days Charlie runs away and
sits in a local park all day just to
avoid classes
do you feel like you vanished from
school yeah
meeting Charlie has brought a national
crisis into sharp Focus
it's hard to find a solution to
Charlie's problem because there are all
sorts of people around him trying to
help
and you know Charlie's not alone there
are thousands and thousands of children
just like him missing chunks of their
education
the numbers are staggering in the first
term of this Academic Year more than 125
000 pupils spent more time out of class
than in it that is double since the
pandemic
to find out what's being done about it
we've been given very rare access to a
special team here in Blackpool whose job
it is to get children back into class
it's called pupil welfare I've worked
for the council in this area for 23
years now and this is literally the
busiest we've ever been I'll just give
you an example
um
about just over 5 000 family homes have
been visited since September through to
I think I'll ran the data on the 17th of
May
and so you can imagine that's that's a
significant amount of work just to
address the
attendance issue
who's in class and who's not is closely
monitored here meetings are held with
parents of children who aren't in class
enough
Charlie has been absent a lot so a pupil
welfare officer pays him a visit at home
this is a sensitive job and the officer
didn't want to be identified
Charlie's school have tried revising his
timetable and even teaching him in
isolation but none of this seems to have
worked the people welfare officer asks
Charlie why he doesn't like school
it's not like how many
kids are in then and some kids obviously
act up
then that's just
she tells him the school wants him to
succeed and get over his worries about
attendance
still don't like it
I just want him in school basically
because he he will like it and once he
gets through the gates
and he gets settled in he'd be fine I
know he'd be fine
reluctantly Charlie agrees to go into
school the following day
school has been really good and offered
absolutely everything to him nothing
seems to work he didn't want to go back
after covered why can't we still do
lessons on the computer
home I know and I was going now you've
got to get back in the same as we like
to go back to work and everybody's got
to get back to normal
there's one person I haven't had a
chance to talk to yet and that's
Charlie's dad James
they both share a passion boxing James
talks about Charlie having an a plan to
become a professional boxer and one day
an entrepreneur James says he's tried
everything to get his son into school
but he's also frustrated at what he sees
as a rigid curriculum that fails to
inspire his son my son Charlie's a very
intelligent comical pain in the ass if I
should say that
it's the way he looks he's doing lessons
that he doesn't need for his future
plans do you agree I do agree with that
I think people should be pushed really
into what they really want to do not
just sitting down doing science or stuff
that they don't need for the future I
wonder whether Charlie's situation
brings back any memories for you I mean
what was your school like I was bullied
all through school I didn't do exams I
left school it's absolutely traumatic I
absolutely hated school he's in the gym
now for an hour and a half every day I
wish he was more passionate about a
school like that but he knows what he
wants to do and he knows what he needs
and he's going to stick to his a plan he
won't change or anything like nothing
and you think he should stick to his
airplane one million yeah because then
if he sticks to his a plan he'll love
him he love it more and he'll do his
best a lot of people end up doing all
these exams gcses and College end of
stacking shelves Asda or Tesco's ended
up sitting in a rut and he's staying
that job because it's what they're used
to and what they know he doesn't want to
do that he wants to push himself to his
limit
but James has pushed to his limit too
he's already been fined thousands of
pounds for Charlie's absence now he says
next time could be much worse I think
the next step would be from what I've
been told is behind bars from what I'm
talking prison yeah and how do you feel
about that well if if it means he's not
hurting himself and stuff like I'd
rather do it all day long before what so
James you'd actually rather go to prison
your son going to school yeah to see my
son that's not going to school
the actual mechanics of it isn't it the
physical the physical trauma that he
goes through and mental trauma that goes
through then yeah my son's obviously
without a question
obviously no one said that in prison
just because they ain't going to school
that's that's stupid but
I just like school so much that if my
dad did go to prison I'd still refuse
because of how much I dislike it
the government says it's committed to
getting children like Charlie back to
school by rolling out things like
attendance hubs in the worst affected
areas
but it seems far from getting numbers
back to pre-pandemic levels been
shutting your home for nearly years and
then trying to get back out again and
get back into the systems they were in
historically it's a massive change of
habit that so there was lost social
skills there was lots of confidence
there's some anxiety and some of it has
crept Beyond anxiety into mental health
issues
the next morning Charlie has to follow
through on his promise to go to school
that's right the morning routine for
millions of children seems like a
mountain to claim for him
school now
everything has built up to this crucial
moment
not good
they're two hours okay
all right come on
let's go
that's why you don't start this
Chinese Heroes
don't get upset mate come on
two hours because she's just speak to
the teacher receptional
come on male we've just speak to him at
least
I can't buy this huh
don't get upset come on
thank you man
what's up
you can do it that's the problem
come on mate
well I didn't want to go in you're only
there for two hours oh no
this is what I was agreed yesterday with
the meeting
just two hours moving
so go and speak to teaching so she says
do you want to come out and speak to us
Charlie gotta go we've got to go and see
you at least
so getting to come to the car no
despite the efforts of two teachers and
James Charlie refuses to get out of the
car
foreign
to the point that he struggles to
breathe and stuff like he gets anxiety
anyway
but then um then and they say if I'd
have dropped him off there like that I'd
worry all day and my head wouldn't be
down to work I would have been
concentrating it just affects work and
stuff like that and then he would have
been like all day anyway so he wouldn't
have learned nothing he would have just
sat there being upset hating on me
because I dropped him off there and then
hating on teachers because he doesn't
want to be there
Charlie's day ends as it began in his
bedroom his story offers a snapshot into
the lives of thousands of other children
struggling with the very concept of
school falling behind on their education
as each day passes Nick Martin Sky News
Blackpool